good evening everybody
good to see folks uh filing in we're
going to get started um any minute now
and I'm very excited for this Meetup for
a whole host of reasons so it's good to
have everyone here for our September
Meetup
um so we're power loan of the year we
only have a few more left in this year
so we are excited to uh continue on this
this uh trajectory we have of doing
meetups
so first up like we always start the
meet up if this were in person I would
tell you I would ask a question who is
hiring and you all would stand up and
say you're looking to hire somebody we
unfortunately can't do that here
so if you're looking to hire go over to
the NY hack our slack if you don't know
it we'll pop the link into the chat and
you can post your job there since you
know I am on camera I get to say that I
am hiring for a whole host of positions
um the one that comes most of mine is an
account executive you can find out more
at landeranalytics.com careers and for
everyone else please go ahead and post
in the job postings Channel we would
love to see everyone's jobs
no but let's see everyone who's hiring
and we love getting people's jobs we do
um we've done a lot of that over the
years and on the slack by the way in
case I didn't mention it the channel is
job Dash postings I see Nicole just
posted a link to the slack so you can
hop on there
we'll be using that slack throughout the
Meetup today if you have any questions
you want to ask of our speaker you go
into the monthly Meetup chat where JD
just went on and said sup nerds so hop
in there and say hi to everybody
um as always we have pizza for the
Meetup since I can't be of you in person
I went and got a pie this is from
zazzies I'll give you the good cheese
lock
you see some nice charring I had to make
this pie
um just minutes ago and they got it done
in about eight minutes from the time I
asked for it to the time it came out of
the oven was eight minutes and I was
highly impressed that it baked that
quickly um they use a very hot gas oven
so zazzies everyone else let me know
where you got your pizza from or your
other food
if you got hot dogs or dumplings or
cereal let us know in the chat where you
got your where you got your food from I
hope it's pizza but you know not
everyone wants to do that so enjoy
whatever food you have from wherever you
are hanging out please let us know
coming up soon uh we have a few
announcements and we'll get started
coming up soon uh we have the r in gov
and public sector conference this is a
conference on November 30th through
December 2nd their workshops November uh
sorry their workshops November 30th then
the conference itself December 1st and
2nd uh we have a lot of great speakers
like David Shore selling stromgren
awesome uh sorry asamatumi Molly Huey we
have all these great speakers and we
have workshops we have a workshop about
NLP from will Don and we have an
environmental data Workshop from Alex
bogosian
there's a lot of cool stuff coming up oh
and we have an art auction so if you uh
if you're an artist and you want to
donate art all the money goes to our
foundation so it's a nice cause that we
support uh this is coming up again
November 30th through December 2nd if
you'd like to get tickets go to
rstats.ai gov
early bird tickets are on sale until
October 9th
and since you remember this Meetup
you're here tonight you can use code and
why hack R for an additional 20 off your
tickets so go get the tickets as a fun
conference I know some of you have been
to it before some of you have never been
it's a really great chance to learn
about how R and data science in general
because it is our and Friends how it's
used in the government and in the public
sector in general
so check that out rstats.gov ourstats.ai
gov and at the end of the Meetup today
we are going to give away a free ticket
to one of you attendees
and the conference is both in person and
virtual so you have options so you're
getting a ticket for free today you have
your option in person or virtual and if
you want to attend you can do it in
person or virtual your choice
there's a conference taking place
um October 6th and 7th in Newcastle
United Kingdom uh it's called shiny in
production uh it's put on by friends of
the Meetup and I think ticket sales
ended today I don't know if they ended
East Coast time they ended UK time but
if their tickets are still available it
looks like a great conference so check
it out that's shiny in production
there's going to be a bunch of good
talks at that conference
we have our October November talks
coming up the October talk will be fully
virtual
um we'll announce the speaker a little
bit later and we're hoping our November
talk will be in person and virtual we
are still working at the details trying
to um secure space
speaking of which if you have space for
any number of people a small big medium
whatever and you like to host
occasionally doesn't have to be all the
time send me a message we are we would
love to get more hosts um once we get a
a pool of hosts we'll build a host them
hybrid more often problem if we have one
host that they can host one month we go
back to fully virtual but we have a
variety of hosts we could rotate through
things are a little bit easier
so with all that hope everyone is
enjoying their pizza and I hope you're
enjoying whatever food you're getting
doesn't have to be Pizza I suppose if
you're that kind of person and you might
notice that our speaker today is coming
to us live in Technicolor from right
over my shoulder
JD happened to be visiting New York City
this week and while we couldn't have him
in person of everybody he could at least
be in person in my office so I'm super
excited for a repeat speaker
um I'm just going to give him a little
embarrassing story one of the first
meetups and I'm talking like 13 years
ago we had a meet up and someone
mentioned at our Meetup the Segway
package that he had written and they
mentioned his name in the Segway package
and the whole room he wasn't there the
whole room burst into Applause
that is how much this uh this man has
his reputation has grown I guess balloon
right in the beginning
um and he's one of the early people
doing stack overflow with r and really
made it a nice welcoming online
community much like we strive to make
this Meetup community
so repeat speaker both at the conference
and at the Meetup
um stack Overflow extraordinaire Twitter
extraordinaire everyone please welcome
JD as he takes a spot thank you so much
thank you
all right y'all
never done it quite like this before
Jared gave me such a gracious
introduction so what we're going to talk
about today is reproducible examples
this is a lot often we do this as a kind
of
um introductory topic or an early career
or a beginner topic uh I used to run the
Chicago R User Group years ago
before I ever lived in New York and what
we found at the Chicago our user group
is about every third or fourth Meetup it
was a good idea to do what we would call
a beginner's night and and we would do
kind of basic topics and so when Jared
said hey what are you working on you
working anything cool I said I don't
really have anything new hotness to
share but I think one of the skills that
I use most over and over and that I
enjoy my analyst being able to uh do is
produce reproducible examples so how
about I give a presentation on making
reproducible examples and you know and
Jared's like that's great we'll do this
and I'm like I want to make it a little
something that's not just you know if
you know how to do a reproducible
example it you know may not sound very
interesting I've had some experience
lately like literally in real life in
the last you know six months to a year
where we use some of the principles of
reproducible examples uh to produce
reproducible data sets to solve hard
problems and be able to get more eyes on
hard problems and I want to share some
of that story kind of at the end of this
uh that'll be germane to folks who have
a little more experience and may seem
new new see new use cases uh for uh
reproducible examples so
uh let's let's kind of dive into it
Jared sort of sort of introduced me
already and
um you may know me from you know Twitter
you may know me from uh from The Arc
cookbook second edition which I wrote
with Paul Teeter he wrote the first
edition uh I did the rewrite with his uh
with his help on the for the second
edition uh that is available free online
at um trying to hide the bar here not
having much luck
Bruno momento can't back up there we go
uh the book is available online for free
rc2e.com uh one of my favorite things
was right writing this book is when I
get notes from Learners that tell me the
the free online edition enabled them
learning are or they couldn't afford the
book or they live in a country where the
books prohibitively expensive and they
were able to get access to it online and
that was valuable for them and that
makes my heart warm and is one of the My
Favorite Things
um
so reproducible examples what is a
reproducible example we talk about rep
bricks
um a reproducible example is a minimal
example of code typically that can be
easily understood ideally by easily
running it on another person's machine
so why do we do this usually we do this
because we've got some kind of problem
we usually don't try to share bits of
code if it all works great unless we're
doing examples for teaching and actually
rep Rich are great for teaching examples
too so this is going to be valuable for
for that but generally we're having some
kind of problem we either have code
that's throwing an error or we have code
that is not performant in some way or we
get we have code that is producing an
unexpected result that isn't what we
expect and what we want to do is get
that in front of other people so that's
typically why we're doing reproducible
examples yeah it's a social exercise
we're trying to share with someone else
um and you may find in many online
communities you will be asked to do a
reproducible example this screenshot I
have here is from a q a in
um that's the artist of the
community.rstudio.com and it's not
uncommon in that forum and also in stack
Overflow and others for folks to post a
question and somebody looks at it and
they say I don't really know what the
person is asking I can't quite
understand they don't have enough code
for me to see what they're doing or I
can't tell what type of objects they're
trying to manipulate in their code even
though they may have an example that has
a few lines of code if you don't know
what those inputs are they'll say
someone may say hey can you do a rep Rex
and they'll they'll post a link like
this that says hey here and here's an
example here's some information from the
fact so to some degree what I'm going to
do live here today is talk you through
this stuff that has been written in uh
community.rstudio.com it's also been
written up in an FAQ on stack Overflow I
didn't create these ideas I didn't
create the concept A reproducible
example is the thing we're going to make
and at the end I'm going to show you how
to use the repprex package the library
at the package in R to generate or turn
a rep Rex into something you can just
paste into an online form and I'm kind
of going to separate the ideas here
between you know the reproducible
example exists whether you use the
reprep package or not and as a matter of
fact if you try to use the rep Rex
package and you haven't produced a
reproducible example already it's not
going to help you much so we'll cover
that in a minute but first let's go
through what is valuable in a rep Rex
what are the elements of a good rep Rex
right so the idea we start with example
data now that could be
um a number of different forms and we'll
look at some of those uh but we need
some kind of data or you know it may be
as simple as shoving the value one you
know in a variable called a right that
that's fine if you can illustrate it so
you want kind of the simplest uh set of
data or objects to illustrate something
you want to show which used libraries
you want to show the libraries that
you're using in your code because that's
often a problem folks don't can't
understand when they look at example
code if it's just a snippet from the
middle they're going to be like okay but
what libraries are these functions right
I I kind of see what you're doing but I
don't recognize some of these functions
where did they come from so we need to
show which libraries we're using
ideally uh we want
folks to be who are who are reading the
repex who have received the rep Rex we
want them to be able to copy paste and
run uh the code right on on their
machine and see what you're seeing right
so the most amazing empathy device is to
take your problem and allow someone else
to experience your problem on their
machine
uh really valuable for them helping you
really value with them understanding uh
and and also we want to rep Rex to do no
harm right so here in parentheses I've
put the RM list equals LS is a jerk move
what I mean is if you put RM uh list
equal LS that's going to delete
everything in the other person's
environment and if that's like the
second or third item or even the top
item in your rep Rex and they're sitting
here taking a break from their work
going to try to work on your problem
they run your code and it blows up their
R environment and deleting all the
objects that's not cool they may have
been working on something right and so
you don't want to do anything
destructive ideally a rep Rex
um could be copied and pasted into an
environment and all you'll be left with
is a few little objects that you created
all right so let's go through each of
these
uh example data there's a few ways
to get some example data uh we can use
the data command to show all the
different data frames uh that are in art
so let's switch over and you know I can
just type data
and I get a list of a whole bunch of
data sets
right so we have air passengers as the
top one
and you know there it is and so we can
use these in examples these are readily
available you know we'll see some
standards in here like um Iris
you know and we've all played around
with Iris to the point of it being uh
humorous
so IRS you know we we often see examples
with mt cars
and that's a common data set right so
these are built in readily available
great option uh if you can illustrate
your problem using those somebody's
going to be able to reproduce it
um here's what it looks like I showed
you that live you know I'm afraid of the
live demo God so I wasn't sure that was
going to work
um you can also build it with constants
so just build it with a constant a
equals one b equals two or a equals a
list of values one and two that's fine
just type them in that's super easy
um here's an example uh we create a data
frame with um you know three columns
training pulse duration we give them
values uh and we got a data frame called
mydf and then if we include this in our
rep Rex somebody else can copy paste it
and they have the same example right and
so maybe sometimes for your for your rep
products you may need a data frame that
has uh you know string columns and you
know integer columns and you know
something like this will give it to you
the idea is you don't want a lot like
here in this example there's three
columns three rows of data you know if
that will illustrate your example that's
plenty now if you were gonna your
question was about doing a a grouping or
a group buy you may want more data right
because you want another record with
strength or something so that you
illustrate a principle that's fine but
in general the less data the better
because we're trying to make concise
examples
the uh one other option that's really
handy although it's ugly and is a little
bit tricky is using D put command with
real data so the idea with d put is you
use the for the command D put and put
some object inside of that R will print
out
a command that will reproduce that data
let me give you an example of that
here we can see I D put head on Iris so
I did two rows of Iris and it just barfs
out this structure in a pretty ugly
format well I just copied that and
pasted it here and then I did then I did
our Studios automatic formatting uh to
make it pretty but this produces the
first two rows of the Irish data set
right so if the the yeah the iris data
set so if if this was in my example
uh someone could copy and paste this and
and get it so let's just let's look at
it live since live demos seem to be
working
um you know just do a d put
on
um you know let's do Mt cars let's do a
head on Mt cars three rows and you can
see I get this I get this structure
command now it's ugly there right it
hadn't been made pretty
uh but if I just say new
and assign it that that's just copying
and pasting that thing
and then I look at new
you know I've got those first three rows
of Mt cars now I recommend running it
through the formatter so you get
something not quite so painful on the
eyes
um
and the and the fourth is to maybe
simulate data right so you can use
random number generation uh to to create
some some random data
like R Norm
if I can type on you know to get five uh
random normal values right you might use
that I recommend doing a set seed so if
I do set dot C
uh 40 well not like that
set dot C passing a value like my
favorite 42 and then I do you know R
Norm five
I'm gonna get those exact same values if
so if I set the seed again
and then do R Norm five again see I get
exactly the same value so use that set C
when you're creating a rep Rex because
it allows the person who's running it to
get the exact same values now it may not
may not in many case matter uh that they
get slightly different values or not but
I like using it sometimes it matters if
your error depends on the values use set
C if it doesn't at least make sure that
the graph they're seeing or whatever
you're doing is exactly the same that
they see that you saw
so we can simulate so that's four ways
we might pass some example data in a rep
Rex
um so showing used libraries
um we discussed that
and the idea that we can copy and paste
and run to others
uh run by others uh that's a
straightforward concept and then we're
not going to do any harm right so we're
not going to RM list equals uh LS
um because we don't want to hurt anybody
we don't want them to hate you so what
about the rep Rex package right so if we
run Library rep Rex what do we get from
doing that well it using the rep Rex
package we get
um pretty output
and that's non-trivial so
pretty output meaning it's ready to be
copied and pasted into stack Overflow or
community.rstudio.com or any other site
that uses basic markdown so even even
GitHub issues GitHub comments
super helpful to give us something
that's ready to go so it just saves us
from having to do like fences around the
code and then you know comment out the
results it just makes all that ready to
go and then we just paste it in and that
ensures reproducibility because if you
can't reproduce it in a rep rex or if
your rep Rex isn't reproducible it won't
run uh when you try to do a rep Rex
um it shows the input and the output
together so I mean I was using rep Rex
in these earlier examples when I showed
these things these were done with a rep
Rex so you can see the rep Rex package
you can see that the results of any
command are put in as comments uh here
and you can see it down here and the
idea behind doing that is if I just copy
this block and paste it it's executable
code because the results of running the
code are in as comments
so once again we got the principle that
we can just copy and paste this and see
the same thing
uh and that's the whole copy and paste
and put into our value of the of the of
the rep Rex package so live demo let's
do this
all right so over here in my R session I
have
a little bit of code and these were some
things you may have seen already in this
presentation right so we saw this my DF
I'm gonna highlight that just this bit
I'm gonna give it the old control C to
copy it
then I'm going to do library
Rex I already have installed so we just
do this to load it and because I have
copied this code into my clipboard I'm
now going to type rep Rex the command
and it's going to run and what we see
over here is what was in my clipboard
executed
and the result of this printed out right
so that's very similar to if I had
highlighted this and done command enter
right I get this down here in the lower
left right same sort of thing now let's
demonstrate what I told you to be true
Let's test me and see if I am lying to
you
um I'm gonna do a new file just new R
script we're going to paste that in I'm
gonna highlight everything and run and
right I get the same result the these
bits here are just in as comments
so that's the power of the rep Rex
package in action so it raises the
question of what is this output
what does it actually look like well
let's let's run rep Rex one more time
to replace what's in my
oh
I'm going to carry on
all right so let's look at what's
actually in the clipboard right now
so we can see what's in the clipboard is
uh markdown
and specifically it's our markdown but
well kinda not really it doesn't have
the right brackets up here but it's
marked down so it is just marked down so
you can use it in sites that support
markdown uh we can see there's fences
here and there around the code block
and then it's got a little it even
includes the whole hey here's what this
was created with and that creates this
so if I copy and pasted this into a
markdown supported website what I get
renders just like what's in in the
viewer here so that's pretty cool
uh let's look at a slightly more
elaborate example
I have this one down here now if you'll
notice there's no I don't have rep Rex
here like in in my library statements
here
there's no I don't load the library with
a rep Rex with the library command there
I loaded it once for the session so when
I highlight this
and I'm going to copy it in the
clipboard
do rep Rex and it's going to pull from
my clipboard
I'm gonna run that code
and you see we're using Mt cars
and you know see in this example I print
out the head of Mt cars and then I'm
going to do this plot
and it's going to show up here
and what copied to the um to the
clipboard let's delete this and paste it
in so you can see is you know the
markdown that includes an image
and you can see the image link right
here
well what in the world
is going on with the image
if we paste that in
see there's the image it has uploaded
our image uh to Imager
and that's how it makes a rep rex that
can be rendered here or can be rendered
in your GitHub issues or on stack
Overflow all right so what's
implications of this
well the idea here is this is public
right so if your graph is producing some
sort of private data
you know this isn't the right way to do
it if your graph can't be shared
publicly the idea behind a rep Rex is it
is uh the rep Rex package is it's public
so if you were wanting to do something
the graph was proprietary it was work
data and you were thinking about doing
this don't run the reference command on
it right that's not what it's designed
for so just a little caveat there
um
let me tell you some stories so this is
about all the Live code I'm going to
show I just want to show the example of
doing this
um and I want you all to ask in the chat
or in the slack any questions you have
about this and I'm going to tell some uh
tell some stories and then when I get
done telling those stories Jared's going
to come in here and we're going to do
some q a he's going to go through some
of your questions so get your questions
in and I'm gonna tell you some stories
about how I've used these uh reprex
ideas in places that aren't uh
traditional you know QA site something
other than Community dot uh rstudio.com
or or stack overflow
um all right so the fun side effect of
um of doing rep rexes excuse me
is they end up being accidental rubber
ducky debugging
so some of you may know what rubber
ducky debugging is I will tell you what
it is the idea with rubber ducky
debugging is
if you run into a problem with your code
or a problem with logic that you were
working on it has been proven and
experienced by many people including
myself if you get yourself a rubber
ducky or in the case of uh Jared's
office a stuffed plushie that looks like
a standard normal distribution and you
explain to said plushie or rubber duck
the nature of your problem and what your
code does and the problem you're having
it is amazing
the number of times your rubber ducky or
your standard normal distribution
plushie will solve the technical problem
that you're trying uh to solve
and we all know the mechanism of that is
when we force ourselves to slow down and
explain the problem and get it out of
code through our head and literally out
our mouths or out our fingers if we're
typing it but often out our mouths
we often see the problem or what's going
on it will Dawn on us I have discovered
any number of times that the process of
reducing my problem down to just the one
core element to create a rep Rex
solves the problem I have before I ask
anybody for help and it's the most
annoying and fantastic thing in the
world and the reason for that is I think
the mechanism is at least for me is I
know to do a rep Rex I've got to get my
problem out of my big chunk of code
out of my large routine I've got to
isolate it I've got to do a controlled
input I've got to make it do its thing
that's going to cause my problem and
produce output in a tight way and in the
process of tightening that up and
getting it out of my bigger code I
discover what's really going on or I
figure out what the true problem is and
it's different than what I thought so
creating a rep Rex ends up being sort of
accidental rubber rubber ducky debugging
the analysts that work for me when they
do their first now we're a business unit
but we use coding tools we aren't
professional developers but we use git
and GitHub for storing our code and when
our when my analysts go through their uh
first formal pull request process which
includes a code review they get a rubber
ducky to go on their desk right and
that's a little bit like their their
driver's license to uh write code
because they know how to do
um they know how to do basic pull
requests and go through a code review
and so we give them the rubber ducky and
and I tell them that the rubber ducky is
going to replace me and they're going to
be partially managed by the rubber ducky
and that rubber ducky does an amazing
job so highly recommend the rubber ducky
all right reprecs for performance
um this is kind of an interesting story
and I don't have a lot of visuals for it
so I'm going to stop sharing
um many of you may remember if you came
to the Meetup that I shared at some I
think it was a year ago or something I
shared an example workflow I've been
working on with very large data sets and
how we benchmarked uh these very large
join I was trying to do with with a
number of different vendors
in order to figure out which technology
would work best for uh for our problem
one of the things that spun out of that
is I'm down at actually sci-fi in Austin
and and one of the folks from from
coiled who's the company that's that
supports dasc uh and they're major
contributors in desk uh having beers
with them at sci-fi Austin and they say
is there any way you could produce some
data that we could share and or can we
share some of the data you shared with
us we said well now it's a little too
close to home but we understand the
problem well enough
that I think I can help you all make
four billion rows of synthetic data that
will show the problem we faced because
the problem we had was a very imbalanced
join uh where it's a mini to mini join
so you end up with more records than you
start with uh and in addition there's a
bunch of skew in the in the cardinality
doesn't matter that what that means
doesn't matter what matters is
I sat down and worked with them and we
created very much like a rep Rex how we
would create fake data I did it do using
random number simulation and there are
python shops why we were doing this
discussion in Python principle still
holds
um and we created some data that
exhibited the same problems in some of
the tooling that we were experiencing
with our real data
as a result they are going to work with
us to test and make sure that we haven't
finished the testing if the behavior is
exactly right or if we need to tweak
this a little bit we're going to iterate
um and then they can create a bit of a
bounty or a test case for their software
platform to say hey we're going to try
to make this specific example go fast
and it's going to be based on this test
data set so by my you know use of reprec
skills uh we're gonna help make some
open source software better because we
can make example data that can then be
used in a test case now the step we have
done so far is make the example data we
will also make example code that uses
that data that illustrates the thing
that was breaking their query Optimizer
or making it go slow or causing it to
fall over periodically right and that's
kind of magical that I can sit down and
work with a vendor who also does open
source software and we can create a you
know and we're talking like 40 or 50
gigs of data it's it's like 4 billion
records but using the same principle
that you would use to ask a question on
stack Overflow
um we can use that to uh to help make
open source software better and so I
recommend you guys are involved in the
open source Community uh use rep rexes
in your GitHub issues right or even in
your discussions uh in GitHub it's super
uh now Jared you can come back in here
well first I'll run golf club for the
talk thank you you know yeah you can
clap yourself yeah
all right so uh the The Immigrant that I
don't know how to pronounce it yeah I
don't know where is how long does that
last is that forever or is that is there
a sunset on that that's a really good
question and all I know is stuff that I
put on stack Overflow more than 10 years
ago is still there now I don't know what
the life length of those are I really
don't uh but it's a good question we
could probably go read the immigrator
imager uh terms of service and figure it
out but they last a long time so you
were posting immigrant images on stack
Overflow because they didn't have yeah
you're right probably no and when that
10 years ago it wouldn't have been and I
don't know exactly when those came to be
uh but no it wouldn't have been
immigrated back then because they didn't
know they didn't support copy paste
images for a number of years but that's
not copy and paste that's uh it's
linking so it might have it might have
been the way actually but I think I
wasn't using the rep Rex package didn't
exist back then so you're right it's
actually that was the constraint uh we
were doing rep rexes in concept and I
think Jenny Bryan uh came up with the
idea of repreks as a word you know
instead of reproducible example rep Rex
and then she made the rep Rex package so
it's um it's sponsored through our
studio uh so I want to acknowledge their
hard work and thank them for that
because it made all that we don't have
to you know when you're doing images you
don't have to upload them to a site and
then and figure out the link and embed
that in your markdown it just solves all
that right so it's such a convenience
wrapper for all this stuff all right
what else you got for me so uh do you
know and you might not know does Jenny
Brian still maintain rep racks or has it
been handed over to someone else it
still has her name on it I believe she's
still at our studio right so yeah yeah
so I don't know let's go I'm gonna flip
over here and just I'll say I should
share my screen when I go looking things
up let's
share my desktop let's all look together
uh rip rex.tidiverse.org
you know so it still has uh Gina Bryan
as author and maintainer all right cool
got a handful handful of other author
off authors
uh so we could go in here and look and
see who's actually making uh commits on
the GitHub but no need to do it it's
under her Aegis yeah exactly it's under
her ages right uh so you talked about
stack Overflow is that still the go-to
place for our questions both I'm going
to ask the two double questions is that
the go-to place for our questions and
it's still the go-to place for other
programmingly language questions all
right so
it is a huge repertoire of good
questions and good answers uh the thing
that stack Overflow really did well in
my opinion is from the very beginning of
their design they knew their front door
the door that developers were going to
come in was Google
and the SEO is great meaning that if you
put on our question
into stack Overflow without saying stack
Overflow in your question just put it
into stack Overflow you will likely get
links to stack Overflow right at the top
right and uh you often get them in
indented and there'll be multiple you
know uh stack Overflow answers so it's a
great repertoire of good answers it's a
really bad place for a poorly defined
question
uh a lot of the really straightforward
questions how do you do this data uh
this data frame transformation a lot of
those will be already answered there uh
there's a couple of beginner problems
that are hard to solve on any platform
and some the first one of those is I
don't know what this is called that's a
huge problem right so how do you even
talk about something if you don't know
the words for it and that's a really
tough beginner bootstrapping problem to
figure out the vocabulary to talk about
the thing you want to do and I find that
sometimes other thing places like the r
Studio Community are a little better
when you don't have a tight grip around
what it is you're asking you lack the
words you like the vocabulary you think
this is stats but you don't aren't a
stats person and so you're it's messy
right if you're in the messy dialogue
Place stack Overflow is really bad like
that's not what it does well and so I
recommend for that you know maybe that's
asking a slack Channel where you have a
trusted environment like you know the
one for this community say What's this
called and then that's your clue to
start searching online and then maybe
you can form a question but sometimes
starting somewhere else if you don't
really even know how to talk about what
you're struggling with is useful so
um stack Overflow not so great if you
can't Define it the the other thing is
anything
that's nuanced and gonna have some back
and forth uh that's not what stack
Overflow is really good at they're
really good at like syntactic questions
where there's like
um this is slow how do I do this fast
and you give an example it that's pretty
good right or what's the right syntax to
accomplish this or I'm getting this
specific error when I do this those are
really straightforward it's not a lot of
dialogue needed it's just really crisp
if it if you want to have some back and
forth and talk about like
you know classes of problems or other
ways I may solve this problem or have
more dialogue stack Overflow is not a
great environment I think a lot of
people's frustrations with stack
Overflow is they go into that Community
really wanting to have a discussion and
then they kind of don't have a good
discussion have a bad time
um so that's more of a uh either your
field a discussion group for your field
that you're in may help you clarify the
question have some back and forth uh or
maybe a slack or a Discord server for a
community might be a better way I find
that the two I use the most are the
community.rstudio.com and then stack
overflow
now you talked about so much stack
Overflow that I guess the communications
problems
um would you say that it's having
empathy for people answering your
questions to be helpful
I as many of you may know I am a big fan
of empathy as a technical skill and as
communities get to a certain scale
my observation is uh empathy tends to go
down and I don't really know all the
reasons for that I have some Clues uh
probably related to Dunbar number and
how we relate to humans when we think
about ourselves dealing with one human
versus we're thinking about you know
groups of humans it works different in
our head
um I would not say that the current
place for stack Overflow is uh is a high
empathy nuanced environment right that's
a little bit what I say it's not the
place to go for conversation when you
want to have a conversation around
something you're kind of looking for an
empathetic response someone to put
themselves in your shoes and imagine
your situation
um it's not the not the best location
for that right and I have found that
um other communities are a little better
for that and they're designed to be
right so some of this is use tools for
what they're designed for and I feel
like that's not what uh stack Overflow
is right now
and if you want to learn more about
empathy you could go to nyackgar.org and
search for JD long and see italki gave
well pre-pandemic about the importance
of empathy and communicating yep so it's
all it's been a been a big talk but a
topic of mine one of the big human
frustrations is when you're trying to
have legitimate dialogue and you get you
know something else like I had
introduction recently where I felt like
I was trying to have a dialogue and
somebody told me to file ticket right
and that is indistinguishable from being
told to f off uh from the experience of
of the user right so that's very much
like the people who go to stack Overflow
and want to have a rich dialogue right
or or conversation you're going to have
a really unempathetic experience that
might burn a little bit uh because
somebody's going to be Curt or rude or
downvote your question or ask it to be
closed as off topic right and all those
are gonna feel hurtful because you're
wanting to have an empathetic dialogue
with a problem you're having right if
everything was great in your life you
wouldn't be there asking questions but
you're there asking questions and the
experience you're getting is you're
getting shut down and that really Burns
and so some folks have have some bad
experiences and I am empathetic with
that but I think the solution isn't to
try to change the most popular
programming site that has ever existed
in the human history if you think your
goal is to change that that's a bit of a
um you know quixotic Endeavor so I
recommend Instead try to match your
needs your level of fidelity you need to
the community to the right Community
instead of raging against stack Overflow
not giving you a empathetic dialogue
and you should check out JD's talk from
years ago about just this topic
um and you mentioned the submit a ticket
I saw you tweet about that the other day
yeah did they ever resolve that I know
we did we did actually and and actually
I felt like in retrospect I handled that
pretty unempathetically right so I got
to examine my own empathy uh when I felt
a little a little upset and I had a
really good dialogue uh you know with
some folks I you know I got upset from
being pushed to trying to have a
conversation being pushed open a ticket
um and and I learned some good lessons
that hey there's a human on the other
side of that interaction as well I was
caught up with my Human Experience so
you know one of the things I always try
to encourage people is to have empathy
for the other human and sometimes I lose
sight of that right and I'm the guy
running around going to Tech conferences
giving empathy conversations I still
lose my marbles and uh and and forget
there's a human on the other side of the
screen and the other side of the
keyboard good reminder for me
I'm going to stick a stack over on the
float a little bit uh over a decade ago
it's that cover flow was first getting
started with the r community at least
yeah I remember uh sitting in a room
like at the with the Meetup actually
there's only 20 of us attending yep and
we're all saying wow stack Overflow is
so nice and then we looked around the
room it was all up it was all of us yeah
and you you wanted that physically room
so when was the last time you asked the
question on stack Overflow it has been a
while I mean we could go in and look at
it but it's been more than a year
I do a lot now of consuming the content
but anyway this is a little weird that
I'm talking to the screen and he's
behind me and I just want to acknowledge
this is as weird for me as it is for you
all watching this right but I feel like
if I turn my back
yeah I know we need we need more cameras
um
I haven't asked many uh recently uh
because I find a huge amount of answers
to my problems uh from Googling first so
I read someone stack Overflow almost
daily
um and when I am having a problem that
needs dialogue often I'm I'm in the
GitHub issues of the people that make
the library because I'm kind of passed
off in the syntactic problems and I'm
into is this the right class of problem
for this tool or am I trying to drive a
hammer with a screwdriver or I'm sorry
drive a drive a nail with a screwdriver
which isn't always the best stack
Overflow question that's often a way
better question to ask on the discussion
area
um of the of the package right so I've
been doing some work with duck DB
looking at Doug DB on parquet files in
S3 and all my testing looks like it's
only used using two threads no money no
matter how many processors I have right
so
um when I'm when when it's on S3 you
know on a local file system it's every
processor is blurring
um I didn't ask that on stack Overflow I
went straight to their GitHub and it's
actually not an issue right like I'm
like I think I'm seeing this and my Mis
what am I actually seeing I wanted a
discussion
so I go to uh duckdb's GitHub page
there's in addition to issues there's a
discussion area and I made rep rexes
kind of of what I was seeing I shared a
bunch of screenshots of what I'd done
what I was seeing I ran timers on my
code and kind of showed that as I
increase the number of CPUs my run time
is not changing and that makes me feel
like we're not getting CPU usage you
know and I explain very carefully what
I'm doing it had a good dialogue some
folks yeah you know first of all yes you
should be seeing a speed up let's look
at this oh let's you know and we start
this dialogue I'm finding at this point
in my journey I'm doing more of those
because it wasn't like what's the right
syntax type questions it was like let's
talk about is this behaving the way it's
supposed to and I really there's
probably a some very small community of
people who know how that little piece is
supposed to work and I know where they
are so I'm going to go ask the question
in their yard not ask them to go
somewhere else right and that's also an
example of I started a conversation with
them long before I would have any like
Twitter conversation about that I wanted
to like make sure I was doing it right
uh so rather than saying ah it doesn't
work right it's broken you know I was
like hey y'all
help me out here uh and let's think
about this and uh that was valuable so
I'm finding a lot of the original
question was how long since I post a
question on stag overflow more than a
year maybe three I don't even know uh
but it's because I'm going other places
because I have different kinds of
questions I think
and did you ever resolve the drb can do
is it running more course now uh no it's
all it's open still uh it's open for
discussion the uh some folks are going
to look at me this was like the last
week right this is all real current
stuff
um I love duck DB for certain classes of
problems it's amazing uh if I'm over and
got parquet files in S3 the answer is
Athena and for me many cases now not if
you're wanting to do a mini to mini join
uh on gigs and gigs of data you'll blow
up Athena and it just it just will start
thrashing and fail to complete that's
what we found in our testing for uh some
stuff we did but if you're just wanting
to filter or group by uh across a bunch
of parquet files in S3 Athena and be
done with it uh there's a library I
can't remember the name of it there's a
really great library for uh uh querying
Athena uh from R and it allows you to
use
um DB plier syntax so use uh you use D
plier syntax and at the end it builds
the SQL in the end it runs that query
against Athena and you know so it's that
same experience we get when using the
plier against databases we can use
against Athena because at the end of the
day Fina looks just like a database to
the system it's just under the covers
it's writing SQL
the library for it if somebody pings me
later if you're interested in that I'll
make sure you get the right name if you
if it's not easy to find
and speaking at WTB if people want to
learn more I'm honest one of the I guess
Founders women's original creators uh
gave a talk at the Meetup within the
past 12 months you go to nyhaggar.org
you can search for honest and we're
talktv and you can find us talk there
about the slides in the video yeah great
tool I'm just crazy about duct TV for
certain classes of problems it's amazing
um so then when was the last time you
answered a question on stack overflow
I
edited something recently
um
I don't even know we it's all public
right we can go into stack Overflow and
look at my profile and see but it has
been a while since that as well uh I do
not
go through much uh
q a in stack Overflow either looking
looking to answer or looking to ask uh
on a regular basis so if I'm answering a
question it's because I was in there
looking for something and stumbled on it
was like oh let me let me fill this in
um how do you approach troubleshooting
problems that come up with connecting
and interacting with databases yeah
especially if they're private yeah
that's hard because we can't do a rep
rex on on stuff that isn't public right
I mean you just physically can't have
somebody else connect to your database
now you can do a reference if you're
getting a weird error at a certain step
you know you can put your credentials in
a variable so they aren't right there in
plain text you can run that chunk of
code show the results somebody else
can't run that though right so it's like
half a rep Rex they see they can see
exactly what you see and you know that
they will have an image of that right
and in your rep Rex but they can't then
uh run it and and that's that's hard
um a handful of things I do is
try to find other folks that use the
same tooling uh it's and see what what
they're doing
um like so the one that that bites me
regularly is
odbc connection to SQL server on Mac
and it's painful
and the answer is
um is free TDS
um
and make sure you're using I odbc
but like I fight that battle myself
every few years because I get a new Mac
and I gotta set it all back up again uh
and I have I literally go like read my
own blog post so that's like not an
answer to your question that's an
expression of my empathy with the
hardness of the problem that I fight
that one myself uh periodically
um
that would that is that is just hard
with PRI truly things where there is a
component that that you can't show your
example
without the private bits so like a
database connection or you know
troubleshooting permissions on in Cloud
environments like you can show somebody
the area you're getting they can't
reproduce that because they aren't in
your environment so you're asking
questions like what settings might
create this type of inaccessibility
and so you can still kind of do a rep
Rex but they can't repeat it so it's not
truly repeatable you you were showing
them what you did but they can't truly
repeat it uh so yeah there's there's I
don't have a really good solution there
there's no Silver Bullet right there's a
whole bunch of hacks around the edges
there's finding the community for that
database that's using R and asking a lot
of questions it's maybe going over to
the DBI GitHub page or the odbc GitHub
page for those two life you're using
those live like you're probably using
DVI you may be using odbc and ask you
know really politely and contritely over
there if anybody has any ideas about
what might cause this class of error
thank you very much for your time I know
you're busy uh it's okay you know to do
that and ask it in their discussions and
I've gotten some help over there uh
you'll also
um the if you're in you know obviously
we're in R the uh
community.rstudio.com has been helpful
for me on some of the odbc stuff because
they maintain a number of odbc drivers
and as a result the authors of those
drivers and people with lots of database
experience frequent those boards it's
bad form to tag them by name they want
to like throw it out for the community
because those folks would get
overwhelmed but I found that if I ask
over there and I tag you know odbc
connections or whatever that the people
who write those libraries often drop in
and give helpful advice so that that
would be my recommendation
um
you mentioned the Mac we found um I
found there were any anecdata but um
multiple 10 of more than one said
becoming harder and harder to do
programming out of math like if you want
to do stand or you can compile languages
or install the right version of R
um have you come across this and have
you mitigated it
I have come across it a little bit now
I'm keeping my stuff going but I just my
my previous Mac died I don't know a year
ago or something and so I had to rebuild
programming environment on the Mac and I
saw a little more friction than they
used to be I got it all running
um and I run
um
I run R and I also you know run a python
stack and number of python virtual
environments and I get it all going way
more work than it seems like it should
be
um one solution is
um use hosted version so like at our
work we have now fortunately I have
professional support in an I.T team that
run this so I don't have to we have a
jupyter lab server and you know we keep
an R kernel in that along with our
number of python kernels and they're
shared kernels so like all the analysts
can use the same kernel so we all know
we have the same libraries and same
versions and everything installed that's
uh that's for Python and then the r
environment
number of stuff of libraries or packages
are pre-loaded
that's helpful it's Linux underneath and
so that solves a bunch of problems I can
solve the database connections for R and
other people can benefit from that so as
opposed to having to fight that I odbc
um battle on everybody's machine it's
like we solve it in one place and it's
solved for everybody so there's a bunch
of advantages of hosted now I realize
that doesn't work for everyone you know
another option is you know run Linux in
a Docker machine and get that working
and then you know run your R Studio out
of that Docker machine and then that
thing's portable then now I don't do
that because I'm it's a little there's
an extra layer of hassle in setting that
up and you know dealing with file
systems
um our Jupiter lab environment is
running in a Docker machine and you know
in uh AWS
um
or in a Docker instance in AWS so that
is a way one might do that as well if
they just don't want to fight the Mac
battle and windows is a whole other host
of problems it's just get yourself a
nice Linux environment and Docker and
you get two benefits one is stuff works
like it's supposed to and the second is
you can take it with you uh right so
it's so it's portable the issue there is
a little bit of file system stuff you
gotta you know map your file system
somewhere because you're going to want
to get to those same files and uh your
your Mac or your windows your host
environment so work that out that'd be
my recommendation it's a good segue I
was just about to ask uh about Docker uh
because like that makes like a
reproducible environment yeah but you
don't necessarily see that phone number
hey take it like you don't see it with
that earn flow or our studio Community
or the nyadgar helper anywhere like
here's a Docker image pull it and run my
stuff yeah
I I think you do maybe see a little bit
of that in more Ops kind of stuff
so like where people are having trouble
trouble configuring whole environments
right or installing uh core libraries if
there's a problem with that now a bunch
of those get buried in uh GitHub issues
for things that have to be installed at
the command line
um you know things that have to be
installed at the at the the Linux uh
operating system level I have to be
installed as root right those sort of
things I do have I have seen instances
where folks are like here's the script
run this to see my problem
and hugely powerful right like I first
time I when I got in my head that uh
Docker was a reproducible computer in
the same way that a reprox is a
reproducible example I was like oh mind
blown right like that allows us that
should allow us to do a whole bunch of
debugging and it does but the reality is
most of the time that's not where our
problem is most of the time our problem
is inside of the language so inside of R
inside of python and inside of whatever
not at the system level where Docker is
sort of operating or where you would
benefit from having a whole reproducible
system so I think it happens I just
don't think it helps as many use cases
for us those of us who are analysts uh
as maybe I would have thought it would
five years ago right
yeah something like then also someone
like I know a lot of people compare them
all proficiently but doctors are far in
concept to them and just even doing
Docker pull Docker run is kind of a a
big ask yeah and I always have to go
Google and re-read and relearn what I
had forgotten uh you know whenever I
want to use it so there's there's
friction there right now it's amazing
because you can get a completely
reproducible system uh but but there's
friction right there's there's learning
curve it's not free from from friction
all right
um were there any questions in the chat
that I missed oh let's see the chat from
what I've been here I can only see the
slack do you know the name of the
YouTube channel this will be that's been
answered let me go down the bottom
that's a new one it looks like oh all
right Dave uh has pointed out in the
chat that according to Wikipedia imager
used to have a policy to keep images
unless they went three months without
receiving any views uh they might be
your mood in response to space needs in
15 though it was announced all images
will be kept forever even if not added
from a pro account only removed if
deletion is requested so quite a long
time if they're getting hits right so
maybe if you're using them on your
internal Wiki
um but it says they're going to keep
them anyway but definitely for stuff and
that might explain why for a long time
the stuff on stack Overflow has remained
is they were probably getting hits right
yeah
um all right that looks like it all
right then just um this is outside of
your experience I have feelings like yep
any tips for doing references for
compiled languages because you can no
yeah it's harder right I got no clue
okay
um I haven't touched compiled languages
in so long yeah I got nothing all right
so you're not on the rush train like
everybody else is right now no really
not I really hope they have a good time
and solve a bunch of problems and make a
bunch of tools uh that I can
then know where in the level of
abstractions I want to operate So like
um the polars library yeah and over in
Python and rust uh is written in Rust so
but it's usable from rust or from or
from python that's great knock yourself
out make me libraries that are faster
you know than the python library or the
r Library you know put an R wrapper
around things I have no you know duck is
C C plus plus whatever I don't know what
it is under the cover I don't care I'm
using it from R in Python uh you know
folks are going to use rust and make
cloud services that I'm going to consume
I think that's fantastic but yeah I'm
not in that World cool all right then a
softball for you all right softball me
what's your favorite whiskey
all right that might have been a
Hardball
so
people like asking people
throw money at that problem you know
over and over infinitely right and
there's diminishing marginal returns to
price so you know you can pay thousands
not thousands of dollars for Pappy Van
Winkle and you know when somebody else
is paying I have and you know I've had
and it's like wow that's really good
um now I I was I was asked this in a
call recently and and one of the things
I wish I could do is wish I could give a
recommendation for a rye whiskey because
there's some I think Rye is a little
less uh people don't think about rye as
like a whole class and have a favorite
and I think they should because there's
interesting rides out there the problem
I'm having is my favorite ride my
brother-in-law shared with me and I
can't remember what it is and I haven't
I haven't remembered to ask him but on
like the value let me tell you the value
of play on Whiskey
and this is going to surprise you as
much as it does me the
um Jim Beam black and Jim Beam Double
Oak are better than they have any
business being I it's the sort of stuff
I I don't usually go around and men to
people and I like Jim Beam take that
jump put it in a decanter and don't tell
anybody what it is and serve it neat
serve it on the rocks and just tell them
that something special your friend
bought back from Kentucky and nobody's
gonna be disappointed and it is it is
not very expensive the absolute uh
sleeper bourbon and this one you totally
gotta hide the bottle because it's
plastic the sleeper bourbon is Ancient
Ancient age so two ancients ancient age
is a Distillery and they make their
older more mature product is called
Ancient Ancient age by this junk in the
handle and it's plastic and it tastes
like it tastes like caramel it tastes
like you should be drizzling over ice
cream serve it as dessert hide the
bottle tell them it's a family secret or
whatever it's not as robust a full mouth
flavor as some but it's so uniquely
caramely and so sweet and you serve it
at dinner and people go crazy for it so
those are my recommendations well Max is
going to be very happy about your Jim
Beam recommendation about my Cheap
whiskey recommendations
whiskey yeah absolutely that can we give
our data influencer a big round of
applause virtual Applause I should clap
for him unless you clap himself uh thank
you everyone for everyone very much for
being here you just say we're cool uh
thank you everyone for being here
um I will announce the October Meetup
shortly in November once we secure the
space for November we have the
conference come out November 30th
through December 2nd we have well we
don't have but there is a shiny
production conference and message us if
you have space we're looking for someone
to host us so if that another round of
applause for JD thank you very much and
everyone have a great night bye y'all
thanks a lot